this I have to bring up which is the
similarities you're you're good friends
you've been good friends uh since high
school and there are some similarities
uh both your fathers uh in the business
you lost your father at an early age uh
in a it's a it's a uh very sad story um
he died performing at a Friar's Club
yeah roast on stage Parker carcass and
uh um you that was a loss that clearly
had a huge effect on you yeah obviously
yeah and and and um he says something in
in the documentary that that I didn't
know and when I heard it I I couldn't
believe it he said that when he was a
kid he used to go to sleep with the
radio on and his mother would come in
while he was sleeping and turn it off at
night and one morning he woke up and the
radio was still on it was like 3 in the
morning 3: in the morning he woke up and
he said he knew at that point that his
father had died CU your father had been
sickly and my whole life you know he he
was healthier for my brothers but by the
time I was born it was not it was not
good and he had trouble walking so for
my life he was Ill always ill so I was
always worried about it so it wasn't
like a premonition I thought this was
happening every day you he um what's I
remembered you uh I had heard about it
and then you and I got to have a dinner
once and you told me the the story and
it's absolutely unbelievable he's on the
friers club de and it's 1958 and he
destroys I mean absolutely destroys and
he's the hit of the night you can listen
to it it's on listen to it and then he
goes back and he sits down at at his
seat and passes away and it's weird
because it's the thing that comedians
talk about sometimes almost in a
whiskful way like I'd love to kill in
front of a crowd and then just quickly
go yeah and what I'm always amazed at is
that he finished you know could happen
on the way up to the mic it could happen
during but he finished so that's the
coolest part and then they tried to save
the evening the insane part that you
they send it your your father they're
working on him backage backstage Milton
Burl says to a singer at the time Mar go
up there and sing one hit in America and
he says Sing Sing and milon didn't know
what the song was he says Go sing your
hit Go sing your hit Tony Martin stands
up and he sang and his hit was called
There's No Tomorrow Jes God
there's no tomorrow while they're
working on your dad in back oh my god um
God and and and now your father of
course uh lived uh wonderful I think 170
years uh and
98 um and was uh you know I got to know
him he was such a beautiful man such a
lovely man so encouraging and uh um
absolutely
lovely the first time he came on my late
night show he came out and he said um uh
I'm going to this my first time on the
show so I'm going to mark my territory
so he walked around to the back of the
show miming peeing it but I don't think
my crowd knew what marked your territory
meant and he sat down and it had gotten
nothing and he went well that completely
didn't work and that was my favorite
part my favorite part was him just
saying that you know cuz any bit where
you have to get
leave the there's the perfect example
was Carl walking around mocking peeing
great or the fact that your audience
didn't like it was it shitty or didn't
understand it yeah yeah I'd say it was
great last night I I was at CBS where we
shot all the family and all the stuff
and they had a special for Dick Van djk
who's 98 turning 98 and uh I opened the
thing and introduced it and talked about
how the first pilot of the van djk show
was my dad did it he started and it was
called Head of the family and it didn't
sell and Sheldon Leonard who was
producing the the show said the script
is great we just need to find a better
you you know that's where he got enter
Dick van and I tell that story I told
that story at the beginning you know
what it's funny I've seen the footage of
the original Dick Van djk show yeah
didn't have Dick Van djk I've seen the
footage of your dad in that role and it
looks insane because it's like if
someone showed you Casablanca but
instead of Humphrey Bogart yeah you know
Ed win yeah exactly going doesn't that
sound like a Sinatra song he never
recorded we just need to find a better
you yes a better
you so uh he was was he encourage he was
encouraging of you being in comedy was
he worried for you he didn't say
anything he never said yes or no and so
I never knew I mean I didn't know it
wasn't until I was like 19 and I
directed a production of No Exit of all
things John Paul sart Richard dfus was
in it and couple and that was the first
time I ever got anything from my dad
where he came backstage and he says that
was good no and he looked me in
the eye and said that so the only time
he ever gave me any kind of
encouragement and I went to visit him at
the had his house then the next day and
he said uh I'm not worried about you
you're going to be okay whatever you
want to do but that was that was already
19 I saw something I mentioned this to
you once and I feel like I fail because
I can't find it but somewhere I saw
footage because briefly you were part of
a a doubles act you were you were
partnered with Joey Bishop's son yeah
Larry Bishop Larry bishop and someone
with like a super rate camera right
after you've done a show maybe it's 1968
6 9 takes you out onto a fire escape and
interviews both of you wow and they're
talking to both of you about you having
famous dads yeah and um I saw this thing
and I thought well surely you've seen
this and then you said you've never seen
it I've never seen it and Larry and I
Larry and I opened at the the hungry eye
for uh Carmen McCrae and we were booked
into all those nightclubs the ones you
know the rooster Tale in Detroit Mr
Kelly's in Chicago Paul's mul the bidder
end we booked into everyone and after
that run he said I I can't do this by
the way before that in high school I had
an act with Larry yeah and uh this is
funny Al and Larry we were in high
school and there was no such thing as an
improv or any place a guy on Kena named
lar Brook Schmidt he looked like Ernie
Kovac he opened his house he called it
L's Lair so you could that was thing
that's not a pedophile no no here here
was the rule creeps right now all over
America are hearing this going that's it
it's a comedy club here was the rule you
could perform there if you brought the
audience so Larry and I had to bring our
friends from high school who heard the
same bits at lunch this time they had to
pay $5 and sit in a guy's house it's in
the living room living room it's the
same thing and they're looking at us
like
okay but what is this this was lunch and
you know well it's it's a club and it
was a guy's house first thing I've ever
seen in this city that even got
strangers together at a person's house
and what how long did that guy thing
last uh till he
[Applause]
came he had a very strange proclivity
very strange
proclivity